so unser Körper mal wow
wo ist das lecker
richtig geil leckerste Kürbissuppe die
ich persönlich hier gegessen habe
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute eine
Kürbissuppe Deluxe ich habe schon eine
standardkürbissuppe und jedes Jahr zum
Oktober merke ich dass das Video extrem
oft geklickt wird und ich habe gedacht
ich will jetzt nicht das Gleiche noch
mal machen sondern zeigt euch heute die
Deluxe Variante einfach zum beeindrucken
für den Besuch oder vor Release und
einfach für euch selber und zu einem
Deluxe Kürbissuppen Rezept gehört auch
dass man das Deluxe artig serviert da
habe ich hier ein Zierkürbis den
Hokkaido Kürbis nehmen wir gleich für
die Suppe aber den nehmen wir erstmal
für unsere Suppenschale das geht ganz
einfach indem ihr den Deckel vorsichtig
abschneidet nicht zu tief denn wir
brauchen ja auch ein bisschen was wo wir
die Suppe rein tun dann schneide ich das
hier ganz vorsichtig einmal ab den
Deckel und dann Höhle ich den aus und
danach zeige ich euch wie es weitergeht
[Musik]
so den Kürbis habe ich jetzt mit einem
Löffel ausgehöhlt ich muss sagen der
Rand war schon relativ hart also ihr
müsst schon die Person der ihr das
serviert sehr sehr gerne haben dass man
sich so eine Mühe macht es ist wirklich
hübsch später beim Servieren und man
macht sich halt einmal für drei vier
Minuten den Aufwand schafft das einmal
mit einem Löffel raus und dann ist es ja
auch fertig und jetzt habe ich den Ofen
auch schon vorgeheizt 220 Grad Ober- und
Unterhitze ich nehme jetzt hier mein
Olivenöl gibt das noch mit rein
Kürbisse Zierkürbisse könnt ihr nicht
verzehren die sind nur zum zieren also
für die Optik da die haben halt
bestimmte Bitterstoff etc also die sind
überhaupt nicht zum Verzehr geeignet
aber das gibt ja trotzdem gleich weil
das ja unsere Suppenschale ist ein
bisschen Geschmack ab Olivenöl rein ein
bisschen Salz mit dazu und dann so
ungefähr 30 Minuten in den Backofen
geben damit es einfach so ein bisschen
weicher wird und den Deckel gebe ich
auch mit dazu ich denke den hole ich
nach 10 Minuten schon raus
[Musik]
so jetzt machen wir die Suppe dafür habe
ich den Hokkaido Kürbis das ist ja der
beliebteste Kürbis der ist am
einfachsten in der Handhabung da könnt
ihr die Schale sogar mit verwerten das
einzige was ich hier wegschneide und
entferne sind einmal hier natürlich die
Kerne im Innern und hier noch mal das
harte Ende das kommt auch noch weg und
dann einfach nur in grobe Stücke
schneiden und dann gebe ich das auch
schon in die Pfanne mit ein bisschen
Gemüsebrühe dann ich möchte dass es
schön weich wird das ist anschließend
pürieren können
[Musik]
der Kürbis durfte jetzt ungefähr acht
Minuten bei mir schön weich werden ich
habe auch die ganze Gemüsebrühe
verwendet aber es kann kommt natürlich
an wie groß er Kürbis ist das sollte
jetzt nicht komplett in der Gemüsebrühe
schwimmen das kommt ihr später noch
alles aber der ist jetzt wie gesagt
schön weich und jetzt habe ich den Herd
ausgeschaltet und püriere das einmal
[Musik]
so unser Clip so wir fangen jetzt an mit
der eigentlichen mal wir fangen jetzt an
mit der eigentlichen Suppe Kürbispüree
ist fertig ich habe jetzt hier noch mal
den Topf leer gemacht alles umgeschüttet
sparen jetzt das sauber machen denn wir
machen direkt weiter ich habe jetzt hier
Agavendicksaft ihr könntet alternativ
auch Ahornsirup nehmen die süße passt
extrem gut jetzt zur Kürbissuppe und da
geben wir zwei Zimtstangen rein wenn ihr
keine Zimtstangen habt könnt ihr gleich
dann auch gemahlenen Zimt nehmen aber
Zimtstangen machen einfach ein krasseres
Aroma daher gerne benutzen wenn ihr es
habt und dann so ein paar Minuten lang
eindicken lassen
[Musik]
so nach vier Minuten ist das ganze so
ein bisschen ein reduziert mehr muss es
auch gar nicht es wird auch ein bisschen
dunkler und habe ich euch schon erzählt
dass ihr stattdessen auch Ahornsirup
verwenden könntet was ich nicht empfehle
ist zum Beispiel Honig wenn ich jetzt
nicht empfehlen geschmacklich und
ansonsten die kokosblütenzucker würde
ich glaube ich auch nicht empfehlen
bleibt bei Ahornsirup oder
Agavendicksaft so jetzt kommt das
Kürbispüree mit rein
und anschließend könnt ihr schon mit
Gemüsebrühe ablöschen und auch würzen
[Musik]
zur gewürzt habe ich jetzt mit Thymian
Muskatnuss Salz und Pfeffer je nachdem
welche Gemüsebrühe verwendet darauf
achten dass sie mit dem Salz aufpasst
meine schmeckt ja relativ salzarm daher
kann ich da ruhig ein bisschen mehr als
rein tun und jetzt das ganze einfach nur
noch 10 Minuten köcheln lassen das habe
ich jetzt gemacht wenn ihr Deckel drauf
gebt dann ist es ein bisschen flüssiger
wenn ihr den Deckel nicht drauf gibt
dann so ein bisschen dicker und sämiger
aber es fehlen jetzt noch zwei
entscheidende Zutaten und zwar Butter
ihr wisst ja Butter jetzt
Geschmacksträger könnte jetzt auch
Margarine nehmen wenn ihr das ganze
vegan gestalten möchtet und Sahne da
geht dann auch eine vegane alternative
das gebe ich jetzt noch mit dazu und
dann kommt noch unser Deluxe Topping
da machen wir jetzt einfach noch mal
fast das gleiche wie am Anfang wir
brauchen wieder unseren Agavendicksaft
und diesmal auch noch Pekannüsse
[Musik]
die Pekannüsse habe ich jetzt ganz grob
gehackt die Pfanne ist heiß da kommt
jetzt kein Fett rein jetzt werden
nämlich erstmal die Pekannüsse schön
angeröstet und nachdem ihr dann so ein
richtig schönen nussigen Geruch
wahrnehmt sind die Nüsse dann auch schon
fertig geröstet und dann geben wir
Agavendicksaft dazu und auch noch mal
ein Schuss Butter denn ihr wisst ja
Butter ist immer gut
[Musik]
so zu dem crunchigen Topping noch mal
einen Tipp gebt nicht höher als Stufe 7
von 9 weil die Butter ihr darf schaumig
werden aber sie sollte jetzt nicht
verbrennen sonst müsste alles noch mal
neu machen und jetzt können wir
servieren guckt euch mal unsere
Suppenschale an dass die nicht
wunderschön ich finde sie traumhaft den
Deckel habe ich übrigens die ganze Zeit
über drin gelassen ich habe es vergessen
aber es ist gar nicht schlimm sie
trotzdem ganz cool aus hat er eher so
ein Deko Deko Zweck und nicht zum Essen
so und jetzt nehmen wir uns unsere Suppe
die Zimtstangen entweder entfernen oder
jetzt einfach drin lassen und eigentlich
mache ich bei Kürbissuppe immer gerne
noch so ein Schuss Sahne jetzt haben wir
die Sahne ja innen drin und haben das
crunchy Topping daher lasse ich es
glaube ich heute weg und man könnte auch
trotzdem einen Schuss Sahne für die
Optik und das Crunch Topping nehmen so
jetzt einfach einfüllen
oh sieht das gut aus ich habe auch schon
richtig Hunger und haben seit Tagen Lust
auf Kürbissuppe der ist auch gleich da
der muss unbedingt probieren und ich bin
gespannt auf seine Reaktion mit unserer
Suppenschale
[Musik]
was das denn macht jetzt kokosschale
jetzt auf Coco Schale weißt du
eigentlich so die erste Reaktion war so
wow was ist das denn für eine schöne du
bist Suppenschale
aber es sieht richtig coole Idee ich
dachte der Strohhalm erstmal ja
alternative Idee auf jeden Fall schön
oder hast du kokos-scheine so ein
bisschen Urlaub so ne tschüss am Strand
und das ist so eine Kürbissuppe so wir
probieren ich glaube das schmeckt auch
intensiver hier halt oder kann ich das
auch einfach essen so reinbeißen
ich kann nicht essen wo ist das lecker
leckerste Kürbissuppe die ich persönlich
hier gegessen habe
vor allem dieses süße da drin es passt
so gut ist natürlich trotzdem eine
herzhafte Suppe aber da ist halt so eine
süße mit drin
also wirklich unnormal lecker ich glaube
ich mache jetzt nur noch dieses
Kürbissuppe
du bist so feiern ne das wird dafür 10 €
bezahlen
Niveau hier mit dem pegasuskern mega
geil
auf jeden Fall Gourmet schmeckst du hier
auf jeden Fall raus
wir sind die ganzen Köche da diese Rache
und Henssler
kommt zu uns zu unserem Kaffee
kritisch alles beugen würde und so
begutachten würde der wird gar nichts
bei uns finden
ich wünsche euch jetzt wie gesagt viel
Spaß beim Nachkochen Leute macht's nach
ich feier das ich bin so geil ich mache
wahrscheinlich echt nur noch die in
Zukunft auch wenn die andere auch sehr
lecker ist glaube ich mittlerweile drei
Jahre alt
noch mal zusätzlich ja ansonsten würde
ich mal sagen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Video tschüss
[Musik]